pour retour des fêtes c'est le temps
d'affronter les comtés de prendre de
bonnes résolutions budgétaires quels
sont les signes d'endettement et comment
retrouver la santé financière avec nous
pour en parler 110 la chapelle
planificatrice financière bonsoir c'est
pas un bon moment de l'année quand on
reçoit les comptes puis qu'on constate
qu'il faut rembourser
c'est quoi les signes d'endettement un
principe all things endettement un
premier signe ça ferait la difficulté
couvrir les coûts mensuels et dépenses
des ménages donc c est l approche des
factures qui reviennent régulièrement
vous vivez un peu d'anxiété
vous vous demandez avec et liquidité
vous allez payer ses factures l'a fait
un premier signe un deuxième signe ça
ferait les soldes accumuler sur vos
cartes de crédit donc l'incapacité de
remettre votre solde à zéro à chaque fin
de cycle je prends en entendant parler
parce que encore cet automne un sondage
mené par une des grandes banques
canadiennes révélé que c'était le cas de
60 pour cent des canadiens quand même
donc par exemple de nouveau capable de
rembourser rembourser le solde intégral
de leurs cartes de crédit
donc à titre d'exemple 2500 dollars
d'achats qui aurait été fait dans un
mois à un taux d'intérêt de 12 9%
si on ne paye que le montant minimum
exigé par la compagnie de crédit à la
fin du mois ça vous prendre quarante ans
pour payer ses 2500 dollars d'achats
avec le montant d'intérêts qu'on aura
plus de 8000 $ donc bien plus de trois
fois plus ne manquez la valeur de vos
recherches
on ne naît pas à donner c'est une très
mauvaise pratique financière et c'est un
signe évidemment d'endettement un
troisième signe pour moi frais
l'incapacité à créer un fonds d'urgence
ou l'absence de liquidité pour épargner
donc d'avoir un petit peu d'argent au
cou rejoue exact ça si on n'a pas ça il
ya un enjeu qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
retrouver la santé financière pour être
capable justement d'avoir un fonds
d'urgence puis d'aller mieux sur le plan
financier pour retrouver la santé
financière c'est comme pour retrouver la
santé physique
donc ça sera pas facile et ça demande un
changement d'habitude
donc vous savez en janvier on parle de
régime et de budget donc cesser ces
programmeurs ce sont deux des habitudes
très difficile a changé donc je vous
dirai pour le faire il faut planifier il
faut s'organiser et se donner des outils
le budget
hélas bien rythmé a voté pour 9 ans par
quoi commence par quoi si on dit qu'on
va faire un budget à partir de
maintenant on se fixe des objectifs
clairs simples réalisables à court moyen
long terme donc être à court terme ça
pourrait être remboursé les cartes de
crédit d'après noël dont on parle ce
soir mais ça prêt dans trois ans changer
les fenêtres dans la maison et notamment
dans 15 ans plein fine retraite donc on
on peut avoir plusieurs objectivement
notre budget un autre truc que je donne
ces d'analysé des dépenses qu'on a fait
dans les 12 derniers mois pour savoir où
va notre argent c'est un signe de santé
financière la plupart des gens en début
au premier budget ne savent pas du tout
où ils dépensent leur argent
donc ça serait une première première
tâche à faire ensuite ça va être facile
de réaliser le budget donc ce que vous
faites et vous prenez le revenu ni tu
gagnais dans la maison vous additionnez
tous ces revenus là et vous allez
commencer par des duos les dépenses qui
sont fixes donc on ne peut pas
s'échapper des dépenses comme les
emprunts l'hypothèque le loyer le
logement les soins les voitures ecce
terra et vous allez même idéalement
systématiser les payements ses dépenses
l'heure si vous suivez les conseils de
votre planificateur financier
donc à la fin où vous avez un montant
disponible pour les dépenses variables
et c'est là qu'on va identifier le
budget pour sur les dépenses pour
lesquelles on a dû contrôler comme
l'alimentation les loisirs les voyages
les
les objets de luxe donc c'est à partir
du budget disponible à la fin qu'on va
établir sa et idéalement s'il vous plaît
vent tourner votre budget par mois pour
faire un meilleur suivi de caisse à
chaque mois comme comptabilité
personnelle pour adapter votre
consommation
au fur et à mesure qu'elle ne pas
attendre la fin d'année pour réagir
à quel moment aussi qu'on a un bon
budget qu'on est en bonne santé
financière mais par expérience les
clients la première année c'est de
l'adaptation
donc ils vont avoir de la difficulté à
saisir s'ils suivent leur budget ou pas
mais à force de faire une comptabilité
de fin de mois les clients savent où va
leur argent donc pour moi c'est un signe
de santé financière si vous avez réglé
vos dettes vous maîtrisez vos dépenses
dont vous savez où se dirigent votre
votre argent et vous commencez à
épargner et constituer un fonds
d'urgence ils ce sont des signes de
santé financière et c'est beaucoup plus
facile qu'avant de faire c'est suivi là
parce que vous avez une panoplie
d'outils en ligne des applications
c'est compliqué c'est long il y en a des
pages faut mettre des plantes car
méthodes simples budget terrain et le
fameux le bon vieux classeur excel
fonctionne très bien mais exige une
comptabilité manuel oui donc de rentrer
toutes les dépenses et les dépôts mais
de par l'exercice pendant quelques mois
où pendant une année
ça va vous permettre de maîtriser vos
finances mais les applications la
plupart des gens aiment soit parce
qu'elles peuvent être liés à vos comptes
de banques donc demande moins de six
donné il y en a pour tous les goûts on
fait donc méthodes plus classiques en
méthode en ligne en 2020 il n'y a
pratiquement aucune excuse pour port et
un budget et si on a besoin d aide
on y arrive pas là oui il ya les outils
on se tourne vers quoi quand c'est
vraiment rendu grave
ben en fait c'est
je pense qu'avec vous trouverez beaucoup
de ressources mais c'est sûr qu'il faut
jamais oublier qu'il ya des associations
de consommateurs les centres d'éducation
populaire qui offre des ateliers sur la
gestion financière il ya même des cours
donnés par les universités maintenant
gratuitement sur la littératie
financière donc un paquet de ressources
disponibles évidemment dans votre
institution financière ou auprès d'un
conseiller financier
c'est de ce sont des bonnes ressources
également c'est le temps et d'y penser
en tout cas clairement senti la chapelle
merci beaucoup
si bien